in the age of CGI it's easy for
filmmakers to use digital effects
instead of actual stunts and while the
end result might look cool
it doesn't quite pack the same punch
however some of the most incredible
movie scenes involve practical stunts
that are so unbelievable you'd never
guess that they were totally real
Terminator 2 Judgment Day when it comes
to pushing the envelope and special
effects James Cameron is without a doubt
the king of the world
but this VFX revolutionary still
believes in using practical effects
whenever possible after all we're
talking about the guy who built an
800-foot titanic replica and then sank
it in a 5 million gallon water tank
however in Terminator 2 Cameron took his
love for real-life stunts to
death-defying levels near the end of the
film the three-time Oscar winner used an
actual aircraft during a thrilling chase
where a SWAT van attempts to outrun a
helicopter in one stunt the chopper
flies beneath an overpass at nearly 70
miles per hour but with just five feet
of room above the helicopter the camera
crew refused to film it so Cameron shot
the sequence himself pulling off what's
got to be one of the riskiest aircraft
stunts in cinema history speed before he
was neo or John wick Keanu Reeves was
Jack Travon a policeman who finds
himself aboard a bus that's rigged to
explode if it drops below 50 miles per
hour things get even worse when the bus
races up an elevated freeway straight
toward a 50-foot gap in the road Sandra
Bullock's character Annie is forced to
drive the bus straight into the air to
clear the gap landing safely on the
other side the filmmakers digitally
removed that missing chunk of the
highway but director Yan de bont
actually got the bus to fly using a
vehicle that was stripped down to bare
bones their stunt driver got the bus up
to 61 miles per hour before soaring off
a ramp built on an LA freeway
mission impossible - when it comes to
performing his own stunts Tom Cruise is
miles above every other actor on the
planet for proof look no further than
Mission Impossible - in the opening
sequence Cruz dangles off the side of a
cliff without a safety net so when he
flings himself from one rock to another
the only thing keeping him alive is a
thin cable later on during an insane
fight sequence crews at a steel cable
attach to a knife and position himself
so it would stop about a quarter of an
inch away from his eye it's that kind of
dedication that proves Tom Cruise is
worth every cent he makes and also that
he's totally nuts The Bourne Ultimatum
in the third installment of the Bourne
series secret agent Jason Bourne throws
down with an assassin and what may be
the best fight of the franchise but
firstborn has to leap across an alleyway
and crash through a window rest assured
there's no CGI here just old-fashioned
practical effects Matt Damon's body
double left from one building to another
smashing through a false window while
another stuntman attached to a wire rig
followed with a handheld camera Skyfall
the double-oh-seven franchise is
jam-packed with amazing stunts from the
parkour sequence and Casino Royale to
the parachute jump in The Spy Who Loved
me but it's pretty hard to beat the
motorcycle chase from Skyfall
instead of using a green-screen director
Sam Mendes decided to put actual
motorbikes on actual rooftops in the
Middle East the stunt drivers maneuvered
their bikes down concrete strips that
were about a meter wide bond stunt
double Robbie Maddison explained a lot
of the rooftops have old
air-conditioning units with metal stakes
coming up things that can stab you if
you were to fall on them it definitely
was not a place you'd want to ride with
no helmet Iron Man 3 we can all agree
that one of the best action sequences in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is Iron
Man 3's barrel of monkeys seen when
everyone aboard Air Force One is sucked
out of the plane the free-falling
crewmembers form a human chain allowing
Iron Man to safely deposit them into the
ocean marvel's executives gave their
movie wings by hiring the redbull stunt
team for the sequence in total these
die-hard adrenaline junkies made
approximately 600 jumps over the course
of eight days with each dive lasting
about a minute
team effort all around go us The Fast
and the Furious 7 & 8 if you were new to
the Fast and the Furious franchise you
might be surprised to learn that a lot
of the stunts you see on the screen are
legit like that scene in Furious 7 where
Vin Diesel and the gang parachute from a
plane 12,000 feet in the air in their
cars the filmmakers rigged up four
vehicles of parachutes and dropped them
from the sky each car was equipped with
three cameras and three skydivers with
helmet cameras also went along for the
jump in the fate of the Furious the gang
zooms in to Berlin and ends up smashing
bad guys into oblivion with the help of
a 14.5 tonne wrecking ball for the scene
the stunt drivers doubling for the good
guys had to get out of the way but the
other driverless vehicles were towed at
40 miles per hour straight into the
equally fast ball of death baby driver
director Edgar Wright basically mashed
up heat the driver and singing in the
rain into one glorious movie this 2017
heist flick follows a music-loving
getaway driver who tries to leave his
life of crime after falling head over
heels for a charming waitress and as it
turns out almost every stunt baby pulls
off is the real deal that includes the
jaw-dropping 180 in 180 out gag from the
movies opening scene our hero throws a
Subaru into a forward 180 spinning
around one truck before throwing the car
into a reverse 180 successfully dodging
another vehicle the baby driver stunt
doubles wanted to capture that realistic
feel even if it meant putting their
lives on the line questions thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]